Some trips are just better in an Airbnb. And right now, you can discover Canada and there are many local hidden gems with an Airbnb. I worked in Canada off and on for two years. Yes. And my first year, the production put me up at a place. And the second year, I was like, hey, whatever that production budget is, can I have it and go find my own place? And like more of a neighborhood, you know? Yes.
And I did. I got an Airbnb. a little apartment. It faced a park. It was so lovely. I loved the host. And I stayed there for two months. Wow. Yeah. And I was near a grocery store. I really felt like I made a little life there. I'm thinking about like the Rocky Mountain areas in Canada where they've got the lakes and the Alberta Rockies. I don't know. It just feels like if you got yourself a cozy little cabin there, you know what I mean? Yeah. Like Banff, National Park. Well, listen, maybe you should consider Airbnb for your next adventure. I mean,
we love it. Love it. When you're with Amex Platinum, you get access to exclusive dining experiences and an annual travel credit. So the best tap is in town might be in a new town altogether. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Terms and conditions apply. Learn more at mx.ca. slash yamex. Hi. Hello.
Sam Cassie. Hi. Hello. Did you forget how to do this? Yeah. It's been a while. Yeah. Hi.
Happy Friday chit chat everybody. Oh, I miss you guys. Wow. Sam, I am so here for your handlebar mustache. I think it's so hot. Really? I'm not a fan of it. I've just been.
I've been rocking it the last couple days. Did you lose a bet? Why are you, if you don't like it? I was shaving. All guys when they shave, they start with a beard, then we do weird moustaches and take photos and then shave it off. That's the process of shaving your beard off. And when I got to this stage,
I had to go get something from the male and never picked up shaving again. So I'm like 80% done with shaving. Yeah, I've looked like this for the last couple days. Women are crossing the street when I walk up to them. Not this lady. Really? Not this lady. Okay.
I'm saying God bless the mail is what I'm saying. Oh my gosh, we have so much to catch up on. How is everyone? Oh, good, good, good, good, good. How are you? I'm great. Wait, Sam, were you in Hawaii? Were you just in Hawaii?
I was just in Waikiki for two full weeks. It was, I used to think I'd never been before. Everything looks like, you know how when in the Truman show where he sails out to the edge of the wall, realizes it's painted on? Everything looked painted on, like all the sunsets, all the ocean water. Everything looks fake, but it's all real. It was gorgeous. The water was gorgeous.
Beautiful. Yeah, it was really nice. The people were so sweet. It was great. I love it. I always think pineapple tastes better in Hawaii. It's like so sweet. Do you know what I'm talking about?
Yeah, I think it's because you're a little dehydrated. No. No. And Jenna, how's Chicago? Oh, lady. I just saw you. You were just here. I know.
I know, I know, but we got to see each other in a very sort of truncated little window of time. But you're living in Chicago. I mean, I left you a message. I was like, I love it there. I love it. Top new favorite city. Yeah, I think it's a good thing I didn't move to Chicago when I left St. Louis because I'm not sure I would have ever made it all the way to L.A.
I think I would have stopped here. I am in love. Did you ever do Chicago Second City? Was that part of your comedy? No, no, no. The improv group that I started with, I-O-West, they're originally from Chicago, for the Pro-Olympic. Yeah.
No, but same, Jenna. I think if my first pit stop had been Chicago, I'd still be there. Yeah. It's amazing. I just swam in Lake Michigan this morning with my daughter. You did not. Really? That's so cool.
That has to be like a cold plunge. It's not that cold. It's wonderful. Really? Yeah, but you can handle the cold lady. You can handle the cold. I'd probably stick my big toe in there and be like, I'm out. I'm telling you.
It's not that cold. The end of the summer, it's so refreshing. It was, what, maybe 75 degrees out, but the sun was warm and the water was warm. And I could walk right up to Lakeshore Drive and go out on the beach. And it was just great. The play, which I'm doing at the Goodman Theater. Ashland Avenue is fantastic. Thank you, lady.
So good. We just opened. Oh, my gosh. I just wasn't prepared for how much I was going to, how emotional I was going to get on so many different like layers because I was so proud of you, Jenna, and you are so good. And I got to see my friend have this moment that I know she just where she's her full self. And then the performances are so great that like I was just, I was crying and then I was laughing, all the things. Well, lady, thank you for saying that because I do feel like I'm getting to express my full self.
And I will tell you, I am definitely 100% at home in the theater with my theater nerd people. Like, these are my people. Oh, nice. Just a hundred percent. And lady, I've talked to you about the crew on this. I love them like I love our office crew. Nikki, our stage manager. Oh, my God.
Stop it. She's so good. All the things a stage manager has to do. She's like the Kelly Cantley of Ashland Avenue. She's like our first AD. She does like. all the scheduling. But she also makes all the little announcements on the microphone that I hear back in my dressing room. So she'll be like fight call actors who need to do fight call. Please come to the
stage now for fight call. But then it's like the sweetest little voice. But then my favorite is like at the end of a show, she'll be like, all right, everybody, that's another performance. We have finished wonderful cast of Ashland Avenue. I'm going to see you back tomorrow at 1.30. 1.30 is your half hour call 115 if you're coming for fight call it's like i need to record it it's the cutest thing i just love her but i mean i love everybody andria is the gal who sits outside my dressing room at a little table and she is my i guess dresser my wardrobe person she dresses me and fran who is the um the guy who plays my dad in the play our dressing rooms are side by side and she sits outside with like the rack of clothes and it's her job before i go on stage every time to check
make sure I have the right stuff on. And you would think, like, oh, you'll have the right stuff on. I cannot tell you how many times, like, I'll go back after a scene and I'll sit down. I'll, like, reapply my lipstick. I'll, like, look at my lines, make sure I know what I'm doing. And I'll walk out. I'll have the complete wrong shoes on. Or I'll, like, have forgotten to change my sweater.
And Andrea will be like, sweater, sweater. But I mean, I just, that's what I mean. I, like, just love all of them. And I love her. And I just, everybody. Lauren Gabe, I mean, I could just name so many people who just are so meaningful behind the scenes. And I am. I'm just living out my dream, lady.
And what I was saying about the Goodman is that I'm staying about a 30-minute walk from the theater. So I can even walk there if I want. Oh, that's nice. And I get to walk past the river. And it's a beautiful walk. I mean, it's just this city is incredible. Nice. And I'm so proud of Lee.
His play is so good. And it's really getting a chance to shine. It's been great. This question is on behalf of the Office Ladies fan Facebook club. Jenna, do you come out afterwards and take pictures and sign stuff? I have. I have come out every night except opening. They had a special event that we attended as a cast,
so I wasn't able to come out on opening night. But thank you for bringing that up, Sam, because I do want to give a shout out to the Office Ladies community. Every night during previews, there was some group of people from Office Ladies. that came out to support the show. And if theater nerds are not my people, then my people are office ladies people.
These are my two people. Because every group of women that I met and husbands, oh my gosh, I have so many stories, one gal flew in all the way from Brazil by herself to see Ashland Avenue. Yes. And then another woman, she grabbed me and she said, will you please take a picture with my husband
because he loves you. He loves you. You're the love of his life. And I was like, sure, I'll take a picture with your husband. And she said, he listens to office ladies. He told me about this play. He told me Angela has a cookbook coming out. He knows all y'all's business.
He loves you. He talks about you guys all the time. You're like, like you're his friends in our house, and he tells me your stories. So it was so cute. But yeah, it's been great. So when they, you know, when I'm allowed to come out, then I do come out and say hi to people, of course. I mean, it's just amazing.
I went on and on, you guys. Thank you. No, no. This is Friday chit-chat. This is Friday chit-chat. Yeah. Angela, you have been to Iceland, and you have specifically now,
you have not shared with me about the P penis museum. You said I had to wait until this Friday chit-chat. So I don't say it. I saved it. I say, hell yeah, I went. Yeah. You had to. By the way, it's right in the middle of like little downtown Reykjavik.
You can't miss it. Like, it's right there. Yes, I went to the Beanus Museum. Okay, for those of you that didn't hear us break down the episode, The Sting, remember when Dwight is trying to intimidate Danny Cordray and he like walks into the lobby? And he's like, she says, that's the biggest penis I've ever seen. And I said, I know. That's why I brought you to the penis museum where tickets are $1,000.
That whole bit, we were like, is that real? Yeah. Didn't a fan write in and say that it was a real place? Yes, it is a real place. It's in Recovac, Iceland, and I went, I should say, that the penises are animals. They're animal penises, okay? It's not like, it's not a human penis.
But anyway, I went. I mean, we've always said, if we ever got to Iceland, we'd have to go. Yeah, you had to go. I had to go. And so I did. Josh was like, our first day there, you know, we're a little tired. little jet laggy. First of all, do you know, people in Iceland love to go get ice cream or gelato?
It's like a big deal. Like, they have their own word. It's a very long word. I'm not going to attempt to say it. But it literally means let's all go get ice cream. And it doesn't matter if it's like freezing out. And it doesn't matter. You're going to get ice cream.
Anyway, so we, of course, got recommended at a great gelato place. And we're going there. And I said to Josh, I'm like, oh, man, I wish I should have looked up where the penis museum was we could have gone by it when we were out to get gelato and he said and we've walked past it three times i was like what he goes he clocked it said ang you didn't see the penis shape rock out on the sidewalk and there is a big rock with two little balls of rocks next to it and i'm like oh yeah oh and then you you go in and you go downstairs and you're in and you're in The penis museum.
So first of all, we have huge office fans in Iceland. And in particular, they work at the penis museum. Really? I took photos. They were so tickled. I was there. And yeah, it's very interesting, you guys. It's a lot of penises.
Penises and glass. Yeah. And, of course, I had to bring you all a gift from Iceland from the penis museum. Oh, my God. You know, okay, so it is the Icelandic pathological museum, I should say it correctly. Sam, I'm going to go with your gift first. I really agonized over this because there were some really great t-shirts. Okay.
Really great. Lay it out of it. And I'll take pictures and put it in stories. Just read, read Sam what the bottom says. It's all about dicks. I'm going to pop the sleeves off that right away. I know. It's perfect.
Thank you. So there you go. Jenna, I got us each one. and then we can take them in our office. We got a penis coffee mug. No. Oh my gosh. It really is a mug with a penis on it.
Yeah, it is. Wow. Also, Cassie, same slogan for you in a tote bag. Great. I love a toe. I can't wait for you to carry this around L.A. It's all about dicks. Yeah.
But it was very interesting. It was. I took a picture next to the sperm well penis. That is a sight to behold. But, yeah, Iceland was so low. Everyone there is so kind and nice and you just get out in nature and people are really earnest, you know? I loved everyone there. I made a really good friend, Yoie.
Shout out to Yoie. He's the best and I can't wait to go back. Yeah, I can't say enough things about it. It's gorgeous. It's beautiful. And I really think we need to have an office ladies road trip to Recovic. Everyone there loves the office. We should go hang out.
I love that idea. I mean, after your trip, you told me you wanted to move there. yes now to be fair i know this is something i do josh says it's something i do it wherever we go we're on a road trip i start to like look up houses there like could we live here and i keep thinking i can live in a lot of places but iceland is one of them okay but angela you also had an insane tennis adventure trip that you got to tell them about i know so i shared this with cassie but i haven't shared it with Sam and Jenna. So, you know, Cassie and I both are, you know, we have our passion. Mine for tennis. Cassie's is for basketball. And I was like Cassie, I got to do
basically the Super Bowl in my life for tennis. And I was invited to play you guys at the Tennis Hall of Fame, the International Tennis Hall of Fame. It's the oldest courts in the United States. They're grass courts. It's in Newport, Rhode Island. Oh, Sam. Sam. It was. first of all, Maria Sharpova's induction ceremony and the Brian Brothers. Jeez. And so I played with Arancha Sanchez Vicario, who is amazing. I met Kim Kleisters. Okay.
You name it. I met them. I also played with the Brian brothers. And, and, okay, I have to just tell one story. If you can tell how dear on headlights I was. Oh, and by the way, Chris Everett and Tracy Austin watched my match. I was so embarrassed. If I didn't get a good shot, I was like, oh, they were right there.
And Ruey Sharapopo was there for the beginning. How did you play? Did you play well? I mean, decent. Yes. I had some winners. I had a clunky backhand, but I had some winners. You know what?
And we were miced, and I was so worried about cursing, and I did say shit four times. But I think all in all, that was okay if you're going to say one. Yeah. But, I mean, let me tell you, the Brian brothers don't hold back, and they whizzed a few at me. And I was like, oh, shit. But I have to tell this story It's the very beginning of the match And Maria Sharapova is standing right next to me
With Kim Kleisters and Andy Roddick And they're like, Angela, you're going to do the coin toss But it went in my brain like this You're going to do the coin I was like what And they hand me this coin And I turned to Maria Sharapova and I go, you do it She's like what?
And Kim's like Kim's like, Angela, you're the coin. And I was like, I don't know. And then so. I don't know how to flip a coin. And I was just like so. And so then we kind of clunky hand off the coin and she flips it anyway. But I just can't believe I turned Maria Sharapova.
And I'm like, you do it. Like, you tried to pawn your special gift off on someone else. I just was so like I just couldn't believe I was standing in front of them. And I just completely computer shut down, you know, in my brain. What kind of coin was it? Was it just a quarter? Was it a silver dollar? was it a special tennis coin? What was it? I always wonder what coins they use in these coin tosses.
Lady, if I was in my body at all, I could tell you. Well, when you go back in your mind, did it was... It was bigger than a quarter. It was a larger than a quarter coin. Okay. Yes. I thought it was a special tennis. I don't know. I'll have to... Oh, by the way, I now text with Kim Kleister's, okay? Her daughter is a big office fan. And so I'm just going to name drop that. I will text Kim and ask her. Can you remember the coin? that I didn't toss? What was it? I might have a big name drop brag, too.
What? Well, you were there on opening night of Ashland Avenue, and you saw that I had a few special guests. My parents were there. My kids were there. Lee's brother and sister were there. And then my manager, Naomi, and Bob, Odin Kirk, were there. And I'm so sorry. Hold on.
That's a big moment, because this story has a great ending. Mr. Eddie Vedder was there. No. So it is a very long story how I know Eddie Vedder and then also how we became reacquainted. I will tell that another time, but I have to tell this story, which is that today, he sent me a text. He's so incredibly supportive and sweet, especially like as an artistic mentor.
And he was so taken with the play and has said so many nice things. And he just texted me today that he has something that he has something, that he he would like us to add to the set that he believes should live in the TV shop that is our set. And I don't know what it is, but he's like, I need your address immediately so I can send it to you. And if you could maybe, maybe you would want to add it to the set. Is that the coolest thing that there might be like some extra little wrap up on the set? What's it going to be? You have to tell us we'll need an update. I know. I don't know. He hasn't told me. What is this set? What What time period does it take place? Does it change? No, it's one set and it's a TV store, but it's this TV store that has been there for 40 years. So it's this beautiful set and it has been, you can see that there's like televisions from every era. So it's sort of half museum, half television store. It has modern televisions for sale and, you know, things like that, television parts. But there's this wall of just,
like every old TV you could imagine through the ages. A hundred percent feels like a story you would walk in. Like, you know, it reminded me of like where we went to get my grandparents' TV, you know? Yeah. It's so cool. The set is so cool. I did round the corner. I rounded the corner and I saw Eddie Vedder gushing to Lee about how much the play meant to him and how layered it was for him.
And I was like, wow, that's got to be. that's got to be feel pretty amazing maybe he has like a little tiny TV yeah I don't know vintage TV I'm not sure there's a lot of sports references in the play as well and um oh by the way Kevin Deppinette is who did the set design I had to like shout him out um but uh yeah so I don't know if it's a sportsy thing or a TV thing or if it's what is a Chicago thing maybe a Chicago thing he's got a rich Chicago history so yeah yeah oh i can't wait to see what it is well cassie i have to um ask you about your trip because i sent you a very long email with all of my tips for vancouver but you guys were you were very helpful you were going you went to vancouver but then from there didn't you go to victoria island we went to victoria and we went to seattle and i feel like this episode is the theme of like travel travel and name dropping so i just want to say when i was in seattle i was like of course I'm going to go to a WMBA game.
Yeah. So we got tickets for the storm and then realized that that game was going to be the unveiling of Sue Bird's statue. Oh, really? So we looked it up and they're like, yeah, get there at 10 a.m. And we get there and like all these like WMBA stars and stuff are there. And of course, Sue and her wife Meg are there and the mayor of Seattle's there. And they're like, we deemed this day Sue. bird day and it was just like celebrating a woman and it was the first wmba statue ever to be unveiled
which is wild to me wow how cool is that and did you meet were you able to like meet anyone or take a picture uh no but but it was just like cool to be there in that moment it was just by happenstance and like it was like one of the best full days because like even the space needle had like a little Sue Bird flag hanging in the morning. And it was just like really cool and empowering. And I was just like, I'm really glad to be here in this moment. And how special too? I feel like those moments are so special on their own, but then to sort of like find it on the fly. And all of a sudden it's such a memorable moment of your trip. It was really, really cool. That's really cool. Yeah. And then I took pictures with the statue. So I can send that to you. Maybe one day I'll actually get to meet Sue Bird. But
that's really cool this was so fun I've missed you guys I know I like that our theme is travel and name dropping I like that you named it Cassie that's pretty good Sam do you have any other traveler name dropping to do
before we go no I don't I haven't met anyone famous lately I think it's the mustache no it is not I'm telling you it is not it is giving me major like Pedro Pascal I'm here for it Okay.
All right. Yeah. I'm just saying. Okay. I would keep it a little bit longer. All right. I'll write it out as long as I can. Okay.
Well, guys, this was awesome. I'm glad we were able to do this. Oh, wait, Jenna. What? Your play was extended, right? Yes. My play has been extended through October 12th. Okay.
That's so exciting. Yeah. Well, you guys are all going to have to give me stuff for our office ladies' Insta stories because Sam, I think we need a picture of you. Yeah, I will. Yeah. I will. and I need one from Hawaii.
I need Sue Bird. Yeah. Jenna, I need Chicago. You know, I need you next to the penis rock outside. I'm curious if it's taller than you are. It isn't, Sam. It isn't taller than me, but the sperm is not penis. Really?
The rock isn't, but the sperm will penis was. Okay. Good, good, good. Yeah. There you go. And thank you to everybody in the office ladies community for all of your support, while I've been here doing the play, thank you for coming out for it. But also, like, thank you guys for helping create this time for me. I mean, I'm going to get weepy if I talk about it too much,
but I haven't been to a doctor's appointment in six weeks, and that is really cool. And it feels good. And I am just all about being an actress and a mom right now, and it feels so good. And I just, I thank you. Thank you. This has been like the end-all, be-all greatest experience. I can't, I can't even believe it. It's been the office of getting to do a play. We're so thrilled for you and we're so happy to help make the space. I think office ladies, we go pee when we want to pee. We always have cake on our birthday and we get to- As many pockets as we want. We have as many pockets as we want and we get to make space for each other to pursue our passions. And this community has been so wonderful and supportive. So I'm, I'm, um, I'm happy for you, lady. Thank you. Thanks,
guys. I love you all so much. I love you. I love you. Bye. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins, our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Calling all book lovers. The Toronto International Festival of Authors brings you a world of stories all in one place. Discover five days of readings, talks, workshops and more,
with over 100 authors from around the world, including Rachel Maddow, Ketourou Isaku and Kieran Desai. The Toronto International Festival of Authors, October 29th to November 2nd. Details and tickets at Festival of Authors.ca. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.